He is one of the most popular and
enduring icons over the American West,
the gentleman bandit,
charmed his way through life,
always keeping one step ahead of the
law with this fabled wild banshee,
terrorize the banks and the railway
companies during the closing decade of the
19th century.
Then he headed south of the border
only to meet his match at the hands of
Bolivian treats.
In this week's biographics graphics,
we delve into the life and
the death of butch cassidy.
Leroy Parker was born in beaver
use R on April the third,
18,
66.
It was named after his grandfather who
helps lead a group of Mormon handcart
refugees thousands of miles across the
country to the Utopia that was Utah.
Traveling along the Mormon trail.
They pulled all of their belongings in
handcarts with that faith and Brigham
young in the Lord.
They headed into the snow drifts
of the continental divide.
Robert Parker senior was a strong man.
That's the harsh winter.
It was too much for him that he was found
dead one morning frozen in his blanket
policy forged on and often many trials.
They made it to Utah Pollock,
his widow in 12 year old son
Max settled at American fork,
some 30 miles south of
Salt Lake City in 18,
65.
They moved to beaver were Max married,
Don Campbell.
The couple would go on to
have 13 children together.
Robert known as Bob.
He was the oldest.
Max polica became a successful
businessman when Bob was a young child.
His father purchased a ranch 12 miles
south of Circleville and to move the
family that they employed,
a number of cowboys including a petty
criminal by the name of Mike Cassidy
Cassidy.
He took a shine to young Bob who appeared
to idolize these swaggering outlaw.
He told the boy he has a shoot,
a gun ride,
a horse,
rope and brands,
and Russell Castle.
Bob was a good study and
by the time he was 16,
he had developed a reputation as a fine,
shortens a competent horseman.
He developed into a solid,
strapping teenager with a
pleasant and jovial personality.
There is not a lot known about
butches later teen years.
It appears that he took work as a
rancher in various locations until 1884.
At one point he gains work
as a butcher in rock springs,
Wyoming.
It was at this time that
he took the nickname.
Butch cassidy was a amash do you?
His childhood hero,
Mike Cassidy Cassidy's first run in
with the law occurred around 1880.
He wanted to buy some
food and some clothes,
but found the shop to be closed on detail.
Z simply broke in and took a
pair of jeans as well as a pipe.
However,
he also left an Iou note indicating that
he would return to settle his account
later.
The shopkeeper,
though he was not impressed
and he had butcher arrested.
The case ended up before the courts were.
Jury acquitted him
in
1999.
A 23 year olds.
Butch cassidy turns up in telluride,
Colorado,
located in the San Juan Mountains.
Telluride was a wild
mining town full of gold.
Hungry prospect is the place
was filled with saloons,
gambling houses and brothels.
Sitting right smack in the middle of
town was the San Miguel Valley Bank.
Cassidy,
he teamed up with a fellow drift,
a by the name of Matt Warner,
and the two were joined investors
in a race horse named betty.
The money for that investment
came through cattle rustling.
They then decided to set their sights
a little higher determining to rob the
local bank.
It is believed that they robbed the
stage in Denver prior to the bank heist.
They then made a show of spending money
liberally around telluride in order to
show that they were not desperate
men on the morning of June,
the 24th,
18,
89 cassidy,
warner and two accomplices,
one who is believed to have been Harry
longer bob best known as the Sundance
kid,
hitch the horses outside of the livery
store in telluride and then headed for a
saloon not far from the San Miguel
Valley Bank just prior to noon.
They noticed one of the
tellers exit the bank,
leaving just one man on duty
to have the Alamo's cabs,
God outside,
while the other two went to the bank,
and amazingly none of the robbers bothered
to wear a mask or otherwise conceal
his identity.
History also does not reveal the
role that each individual plate.
We do know though that one of the men
who went into the bank approach the loan
tatler and told him that he wanted to
cash a check when the man began to inspect
the track has had,
was grabbed and shoved into
the desk at this point,
so the two outside came in and for began
ransacking the bank in such a money,
they go away with more than
$20,000 on the way out of town.
Cassidy and one over
recognize by two men still.
They managed to get away hiding out
in a remote area of southeastern Utah,
known as robber's roost.
This would become a
favorite place of escape.
The cassidy and his gang,
who builds cabins there and catch this
stone and cattle horses and weaponry in
this area.
Cassidy used some of the profits from
that bank job to buy a ranch near Dubois,
Wyoming.
In 1894,
he began a relationship with a teenage
girl by the name of Anne Bassett,
who was the daughter of a wealthy cattle
rancher for four years after the San
Miguel Valley bank robbery.
Butch managed to live the
life of a law abiding citizen.
However,
shortly after becoming involved with
and he was arrested for horse stealing,
his trial took place in Monza,
Wyoming.
Guns resulted in his conviction and
sentence to two years imprisonment at the
Wyoming state penitentiary and Laramie.
Cassidy proved to be a model prisoner.
He applied to the Wyoming
governor for a Audi release.
This was agreed on the condition that
he would stay out of trouble in the
future.
Butch,
he agreed,
but he had no intention of
following through on that promise.
Immediately upon his
release on January the 19th,
18,
96,
he rejoined his gang.
That's an area of their
robin's roost hideaway,
known as the hole in the wall.
It was following butches release from
Wyoming state penitentiary that he and his
wild bunch gang began their
crime spree and honest.
The gang was in,
launched more than 30 members with a core
of such notables as the Sun Dawns Kid,
kid curry,
and I was a lay on the
afternoon of August the 13th,
18,
96,
three men in Montpellier,
Idaho.
They dismounted in front of the bank and
then to have them pulled that bandannas
over their faces,
the bend quickly pulled out that
revolvers and the two wearing bandanas.
How did the men into the bank inside
were a number of customers and bank
employees.
Everyone except for one of the cashiers
was ordered to line up against the wall.
One of the rabbids who is believed to
have been cassidy kept his gun trained on
the terrifying customers while
another filter bags with cash,
gold and silver that before
leaving with that $7,000,
but cassidy or did the people to wait
for 10 minutes before raising the alarm.
The Robo who had remained downside bald
makes was the only one who did not cover
his face.
He was recognized by the town residents
and ended up being one of only three
people.
It was captured and
convicted of the crime.
Cassidy was well known in Utah,
runs as a result,
as a general rule of not
committing crimes in that state.
However,
in April of 18,
97 be made an exception to that rule.
His target was the payroll of the Pleasant
Valley Coal Company and cost gate.
This was the largest coal
mine in Carbon County,
Utah.
Furthermore,
it was ideally located between the gangs
favorite high downs of robbers roost
and Brown's hole.
The company knew that that payroll
was an enticing prize for bandits,
and so they tried to prevent heists
by keeping irregular paydays.
The payroll came in on a train
that was heavily guarded.
Butch decided there's going
off against the train,
was too risky,
and so he did tell him and take the
money directly from the payment stuff in
order to do so high for the gang,
would need to know when the
payroll was going to arrive.
On April the 17th cassidy road into the
town of castle gate and went to one of
the saloons were inquired if there
was any work going for a run hand.
He was told that the might be if he
was patient enough with his excuse for
hanging around now established.
He made his way to the train depot.
He watched the goings on
as the train came and wins,
and then returned to the
saloon for the next week.
He repeated this process,
observing every train that came into town
on April the 22nd cassidy's patients.
It was finally rewarded
a whistle from the mine,
announced that it was payday.
When the train arrived,
butch watched from a distance
is the paymaster fit.
Coffins.
Aaron's,
a couple of aides,
carried money bags from
the train to his office.
The bags were heavy.
You containing more than $7,000 in
gold and I have a $100 in Silva,
so the men were going slowly
then just as a ready decline.
The stands for the paymasters office.
Calvin's a was approached from behind
and a revolver was poked into its rips.
Butch informs him that he was about to
relieve him and his pals of their load.
Adding the did hate to
have to shoot any of them.
Competency was stunned that such a
brazen attack would be attempted in broad
daylight.
There were plenty of miners arounds,
but very few of them spoke English or
would have been aware of what was going
on.
Gang member Elza lay and the from the
shadows and helps butch take possession of
the moneybags coffins
that and his helpers,
left them to it,
seeking protection in
the nearby Howard West.
All the paymaster then began
yelling out that had been robbed.
Cassidy and lay attempted to mount their
horses well stealing the money and that
saddlebags if a butcher,
his horse got spooked and took off,
leaving him standing in the middle of the
street with a bag of gold in his hand,
lay managed to track the horse
down and bring it back to the two,
and they made away with
over $7,000 in gold.
They left the bag of silver
just lying in the street.
Payments to compensate and
out sprang into action.
He ran for the Telegraph office,
instructed the to send an urgent
message to the authorities in price,
which was some 10 miles away.
However,
the clerk told him the lines
had been cut thinking fast.
He made for the train and told the
driver to hightail it to price.
As the train chugged along,
it went right past the fleeing Roberts.
It took several hours before the sheriff.
It price could get a posse organized.
In addition to having this headstart,
butch was also very familiar with the
countryside and was easily able to evade
as as local ranches.
We're also happy to provide
his gang with fresh horses,
having no loyalty to the big
mining companies or indeed
the banks constantly in
Lei.
They made it a bag so that base had
robber's roost where they lay low with the
other gang members.
The officials in Utah were well
aware of where the robbers were,
but showed no enthusiasm
for going after them.
As a result of the local papers began
to accuse the lawman of cowardice for
three months,
butch and his men spend
their time drinking,
gambling and horse riding.
Then when the boredom was too much,
they decided to go out and
start spending that takings.
They ranged around buying fine clothes,
getting hack accounts,
and spending up launch in
the saloons and the brothels.
By the end of June 19,
97,
it was time to get back to
the business of robbery.
The Guy who said that science
on the town of Belle fourche,
north of black hills.
On June the 28th,
Butch send gang member Tahmo
day to scout out the town.
The plan was to rob the bank
once a day had gotten back,
however the day managed to get himself
drunk and didn't return to camp until it
was 40.
Relate an angry butch had to
delay the heist for 24 hours.
The next day,
Butch selected the Sun Don
skid along with George Curry.
Walter put me and Tomo Day to do the job.
That's the Butte county bank.
The three men followed
the usual procedure.
Drawing their revolvers is enforcing the
customers to stand along the wall with
their hands in the APP.
However possible.
I saw this through the window
and they raised the alarm.
Chaos erupts it on the streets.
There's people rush to get off the
street while others went for that.
Guns,
the bandits inside,
they quickly realized that
they had been found out.
They rushed out,
firing their guns in the air and
attempting to get away a couple of towns.
People returned fire from behind.
Cover good.
Carrie was unable to get to his horse,
so trying to mountain mule only
to discover that it wouldn't move.
As the other two rode out of town,
Tom O'day attempted to steal
away into a side street,
but it was caught and held overnight
and the local bank vaults before being
transported to the jail and deadwood
the very day the robbery had been an
unmitigated disaster.
It had cost the gang a valued member
and earns them just $97 leaving behind
$3,000
and the early morning hours of June,
the second 80 slash 99,
the wild bunch pulled off one of the
most celebrated crimes to two members of
the gang with redlands and flags down
the Union Pacific overlands flyer train
just outside of the
Willcox station and Wilcox,
Wyoming.
The driver thought the two
men were warning him that
the driving rain has washed
out and approaching bridge.
He threw on the brakes and bring
the train to a screeching halt,
but what is all of the men had guns drawn.
He realized the truth and began running
down the track to want to come and
drains to back off the bandaid can go
and jumps onto the train where they
ordered the engineer to pull the train
into a nearby trestle on the far side of
the bridge.
Once the train had crossed over,
one of the bandits lit the
fuse to stash of dynamite,
which had been placed on the bridge.
The bridge was damaged enough that the
second drain would be unable to follow
the train engineer then,
or did the train forward another two
miles where the rest of the gang we're
waiting.
The robbers then made their
way to the express call.
I need to find out that the god see
he wasn't going to open the door,
so they decided to let me say,
but with dynamize,
this Russell,
the god,
to the extent that he couldn't remember
the combination to the safe so well,
the robbers blue,
that open as well.
The result was that all the
cash went flying everywhere,
still the gang managed to get away
with more than $50,000 worth of cash,
gold and jewelry.
The robbery made national headlines and
brought the wild bunch to the attention
of the nation's premier crime fighters,
the Pinkerton Detective
Agency for the next two years,
the pinkertons doggedly
tracked down the gang.
Meanwhile,
the policy was formed to
chase down the train robbers.
They caught up with a three bandits.
On June the sixth,
that Castle creek a gun battle ensued
in which kid car he shot and killed the
sheriff leading the posse.
The posse members then with
drew is the outlaws escaped.
Butch Cassidy was north of
the rough and tumble molds,
most of his contemporary outlaws where
he was an extremely sociable man who was
a great conversationalist.
We're not engaged in criminal activity.
Hey impressed others with
his strong work ethic.
By 18,
99,
he had a thriving ranch in Dubois,
Wyoming,
and it was growing tired
of the outlaw life.
In the summer of that year,
he visited the office of
Attorney Orlando Powers in Ogden,
Utah.
He explained to the attorney that he
had been portrayed as a vicious criminal
when in fact he has never hurt
anybody and it only have a role,
but for large corporations,
Bush.
Then jd powers do approach the governor
on his behalf seeking an amnesty deal.
The lawyer responded that a deal was
extremely unlikely and the best thing that
butch could do was to go back into hiding.
Undeterred.
Butch sought out another attorney.
This time the meeting
was arranged with Utah.
Governor Abbott Wells.
Wells was impressed by
cassidy and told him this.
As long as there were no
outstanding murder warrants for him,
he was sure that amnesty
could be arranged.
The second meeting was arranged which
butcher attended in full confidence.
He was surprised to learn however that
the governor's office had uncovered and
outstanding murder warrants in his name.
Butch protest is that it never
killed a man in his life.
He didn't have to.
Though the governor responded,
the charge was enough.
Immense.
Amnesty was simply out of the question
with the failure of his
attempt to go straight.
It seems that butch carried out a string
of further robberies around the turn of
the century.
Don't have been linked to
a train robbery in Tipton,
Wyoming in August of 1900 and the
winner mark in Nevada bank heist a month
later,
though there is no concrete evidence
that they took part with no prospects to
end is fugitive life in the west,
which began making plans to head south
of the border when he proposed the idea
to his gang members.
Seventy two were interested the sundance
kid and could carry before the gang
split up for good.
It's five core members out
of final rendezvous in Texas.
Also having their fill of liquor,
fine dining and women.
They sat for a group
photograph in new suits.
The photo that was taken on that day
made its way to the Pinkerton detective
agency and it was used on wanted posters.
Butch and Sundance then split up promising
to meet up again in New York City.
This they did with Sundance
being accompanied by his
longtime girlfriend at a
place.
The trio boarded the ship bound for
when our series on February the 20th,
1,901
immediately upon arrival books using
the assumed name of Jim Rohn deposit of
$12,000 in a local bank is the first
step and putting up a land claim.
They ended up purchasing 17,000 acres
of lands and shall Lilo to their
neighbors.
There appeared to be hardworking,
gringos z except for one disturbing facts.
Wherever they went,
they wore that guns.
Butch and Sundance said,
presumed that a move out of the country
would bring it in to that pursuit by the
pinkertons,
but they were mistaken.
Robert Pinkerton,
the head of the agency sends a letter
to the [inaudible] police chief with
descriptions and photos of the dealer.
The local police identified them as the
two ranches who always wore guns around
cello.
They attempted to keep it
close surveillance on the man,
so all the pinkertons
arrived and apprehended them.
The two animals would spend seven years
in Argentina before the law finally
caught up with them for
the first five years.
They kept that noses clean.
Blending in with the locals
and becoming popular members.
Of the trinity,
low community.
Then for some reason they returned to
a life of crime in the spring of 19.
Oh,
six.
They teamed up with another
American fugitive and Robin
to the bank and Mercedes
getting away with $20,000.
However,
one of the three robbers shot
and killed a bank teller.
Once again,
butch and sundance were on the run
on November the sixth.
It was made their way
to send the incentive.
Bolivia,
they were put up in the spare
room of a local villager.
However,
a local official identified them and
notified members of the Bolivian cavalry.
The room were butch and sundance
were holed up with surrounded.
There are a number of versions as
to how the last moments played out.
The most accepted version is that sun
don't sprint it out onto the patio in a
desperate attempt to get some rifles.
These were located by an outside wall.
Lindsay was firing his revolvers into
the errors of distraction as he ran.
However,
he was cut down before he made it off.
The patio.
Butch ran out after him and
dragged is mortally wounded.
Friends back inside,
sustaining at least one
wound in the process.
After pouring masses of lead into the
building and hearing one silence from
within the Bolivian troops
finally made their way inside.
They found the bodies of the
two outlaws lying on the floor.
Sundance had been shot several times
in the arms and once in the forehead,
while butch had a bullet
hole in the temple,
the soldiers is in fudge that books should
put his best friend out of his misery
before turning the gun on himself.
However,
there was never an inquest and the two
men were never formally identified.
The most wanted men in America was
simply buried in unmarked graves.
So already have you found this video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe.
Brand new videos just like
this every day of the week.
If you look at something
else to watch right now,
do you check out our other
videos linked to on the screen?
And as always,
thank you for watching.